we're always going to have problems in
life learning to live well is accepting
that we are going to have problems and
face challenges but that will often come
out on the other side of them better if
we accept that and act accordingly
michaelis welcome to the show hey thanks
for having me i'm excited to be here me
too man why are you interested in
discomfort seems like a weird thing to
be interested in
i guess it yeah it kind of is
so my background is i've been a health
and performance journalist my entire
career so i worked at men's health for a
pretty long time in the us and
pretty early in my career i noticed that
everything that i was writing about in
terms of lifestyle health and how to
improve your health i usually have to go
through some form of discomfort to see a
benefit so if i want to improve my
fitness i have to work out working out
sucks right i want to lose weight
probably going to have to eat less i'm
going to be hungry being hungry sucks
even mental health improving your mental
health right you usually have to
unpeel some sort of psychological onion
and get to the bottom of what is causing
this issue right and that can often be
uncomfortable so i noticed that and then
i just had a handful of events in my
life that really sort of cemented that
concept
and yeah that led me to ultimately right
the comfort crisis you went on
an experience to the arctic with a
friend of yours and that was one of the
big parts of this
yeah i did so the guy's name is donnie
vincent and he is a back country bow
hunter and filmmaker
um
he makes these movies that i like to
describe as planet earth but with
hunting so they're not like your typical
you know it's like the opposite of
planet earth david attenborough being
very gentle with some monkeys in a
forest here's some guy stood next to a
huge deer that he's just shot with a bow
yeah well it's almost like it's got the
same vibe and then all of a sudden it's
like dead
we killed the animal yeah
um no they're really interesting though
and i think that what's important about
him is he's really changing how
hunting is perceived and how it's
practiced he's kind of at the forefront
of this movement um that's really
changing hunting
so i met him through doing a story about
him in men's health
a handful it was maybe five six years
ago and we just stayed in touch right
and the story was super popular in men's
health we stayed in touch
and he calls me up one day and he goes
hey i'm going up to the arctic for more
than a month you want to come along
and you know my
initial reaction is uh hell no
but he's a good salesman he gets in on
the sales pitch right he's like dude
it's going to be the most epic adventure
you could ever be on we're gonna see
grizzly bears packs of wolves we're
gonna climb ancient mountains and cross
glacial rivers and on and on and on
right and i live in las vegas and i'm at
home sitting on the couch in my
air-conditioned home you know and i'm
thinking to myself yeah that sounds like
me
you know
so i sign on and uh
yeah i start training i get my plane
tickets up there i have to totally like
overhaul how i'm living to get uh
prepared for a journey like that and we
ended up spending more than a month up
in the arctic on this pretty epic uh
backcountry hunt so we were you know
hundreds of miles from other people i
mean middle of nowhere it's like
middle of nowhere and it was
uncomfortable and i think you know what
i what i drew from that is um
we have we as humans have really
engineered uh
comfort into our lives in so many
different ways i mean i think that
there's ways that are uh quite obviously
graspable so the fact that we don't
really need to put physical effort in to
live anymore
right like you could have 1 000 steps a
day
and be fine right would not have been
possible
a thousand years ago because you're
having to hunt and gather for your food
whatever it might be um
we live in set we live at 72 degrees now
right we have food that is easily
accessible we don't necessarily have to
work for it but we've even put in things
like you know people tend to feel
uncomfortable in silence
well today we've like raised the the um
loudness of the world like fourfold and
on and on and on so in the book i really
single out these
what i consider really important forms
of discomfort um that we evolved to face
that naturally kind of keep us healthy
that we have engineered out of our lives
what was the scariest or most
uncomfortable part of the trip that you
took up to the arctic
oh yeah that's a good question so i
think that what's interesting is that
when i talk about grizzly bears people
are always like oh my god grizzly bears
like everyone wants to know about
grizzly bears
you look at the you look at the numbers
it's like
the crappy little planes you have to fly
to get out there i mean they're like
these two seaters they're packed the
size of a pack of gum
they crash all the time like
statistically that's way more likely to
kill you that and the weather right
so
probably the most dangerous thing we did
was taking the planes in i could say the
most dangerous part of the trip was
getting there yeah it was getting there
but then we also had some pretty gnarly
weather a couple times we almost lost
our shelter one night there was like
this
hurricane
force winds that were threatening to
just like blow our shelter into russia
more or less and
rule number one of surviving out in the
wild is making sure that you have a
shelter because if you don't you're
exposed and it's easy to uh yeah find
yourself in quite the pickle so where
were you on the architect because
obviously it's a big ring above what
were you directly above yeah so we're in
the alaskan arctic
we're about maybe 150 miles above the
arctic circle
pretty high then yeah pretty high
there's a there's an area called
the no attack uh national preserve which
is where we were what was the day and
night cycles like based on the time of
year you were there
pretty long days i think the sun would
go down at maybe
i'm having trouble remembering like
maybe 10 and then it would i don't know
what time it got up because i was always
so tired at the end of the day that i
would just like you know sort of sleep
in and be up but what was interesting is
that we were so high
that we were losing i think it was like
six or seven minutes
every single day so being up there for
that long it was like you know when we
first got up there the sun was going
down at whatever it might be 10 11. by
the time we left it was you know much
earlier than just purdue days yeah have
you read uh endurance by alfred lansing
about ernest shackleton's trip across
the antarctic have you ever read that i
haven't oddly enough everyone recommends
it to me um it's on my list but i
haven't read it
add another person to the list of those
that are annoying you about the fact
that you need to read that but all right
on
dude
hearing that because they're out there
for i think the best part of two years
and when you hear about just how
savage those conditions are you know
electing to go and do that
i suppose there is glory associated with
it but the glory of whatever it was 1914
i think they're left
they left like three days after world
war one was announced and what happened
was
they sent a letter
maybe even to the king
i think shackleton sent a letter to the
king saying
i understand that i'm taking
20 good men of fighting age
some of whom have experience in war
uh and on
yomping to the other side of the planet
to go and do this stupid thing
we'll
stop all of it we'll keep endurance in
port which was the name of the boat and
we will come back and fight and they
waited for a couple of days and they
just got a letter that a telegram that
said go so they're going to go which is
pretty dope um yeah but dude hearing
what they had to put up with
um and
the fact that you elected to do that is
do you think this is something i think
about all the time
the difference between elected and
unelected suffering or elected and
unelected discomfort you know the
difference between
things being hard in life because you've
elected to go and do a difficult
crossfit workout or things being hard in
life because you've just snapped your
achilles
you know both of them are
health
uh challenges
uh physical physical discomfort um but
one of them you chose and the other one
you didn't and i'm quite
i'm quite interested in the difference
between those two i think a lot of the
time
people confuse one for the other
people who are into
um getting comfortable being
uncomfortable training hard maybe
brazilian jiu jitsu or endurance running
or crossfit or whatever
um
but speaking as someone that thought
that he had a good amount of resilience
and then snapped an achilles two years
ago
it crosses over a little bit but it
doesn't cross over that much and there's
a big difference between those two
so yeah i'll answer that two ways um
first off
you have to realize it's like
why do we want to be comfortable in the
first place
why do humans tend to always do the next
easiest thing right it's because for
millions of millions of years we lived
in these environments of discomfort
where life was inherently hard right
there was not enough food we had to work
for that food there was danger there was
a lot of risks that were wired to avoid
all risk
right so doing the the least risky
easiest most comfortable thing that kept
us alive
right that gave us a survival advantage
great
well recently especially within the last
100 years
our environments have tipped to those of
comfort
where now it is very easy to just do the
easiest thing right we've sort of
engineered comfort into our lives we
still have this drive to do the next
most easy thing
so i think that's why
you we need to consciously think about
inserting discomfort back in our life
however that may be right so we choose
to do a crossfit workout
and undergo that suffering
as a replacement for the suffering we
used to have in the past
right that now keeps us healthy and
fights back against this environment we
lived it we now live in
that it's taken movement from our day
that's put a ton more food into our
lives than we ever had before right so
it's kind of an antidote and then the
second part the way i'll answer that is
that
when you look at the research on um
people who have faced trauma or hardship
or challenge in their life
people who have faced a ton of that kind
of stuff
they have a lot of mental health
problems okay
but at the same time
people who have not faced really any
challenges
or trauma they have equally poor rates
of mental health so there is a sweet
spot where you need enough challenge in
your life and this is stuff that is
unplanned
um but not too much so part of it is
finding that sweet spot and i think that
um a lot of times what you find is that
people in retrospect so long as they
haven't gone through complete hell
they look back and report oh that was
actually a blessing because it led me to
xyz now that could just be some weird
quirk in the human brain
i don't really care what it is i just
care that it tends to make people more
resilient
yeah whether you're post talking it or
not
if you come out the other side and you
feel better then it's like the it's like
an experiential placebo pill kind of and
if it works it works i read a study
a while ago that said 66 of people
report post-traumatic growth
rather than post-traumatic stress after
going through something
and
i then read another study which refuted
that which is just like the problem of
epistemics in the 21st century i suppose
that for every study that says
something's good there's another one
that says that that might be wrong
but
from my own personal experience
absolutely the times when i've gone
through something which has been
unelected and difficult um maybe that's
because i haven't crossed that threshold
into something which would be
unrecoverably traumatic
um and
that's what you're saying kind of there
is a sweet spot between the two you know
some absolute catastrophe of losing your
entire family in a plane crash or
something is probably pushing it a
little bit far
but you know snapping an achilles or
having to deal with being poor for a
while or having to deal with you know
losing a
person that you really loved or whatever
you know difficult breakup and stuff
like that
a lot of the time when you look back
those are the lessons that expedited
growth and really took you to the next
level in life
yeah i think so and i mean a lot of it
is how
you know i think that
between
the event happening
and the processing of it um over the
long run there's often a choice
right it's like how am i gonna how am i
gonna frame this uh and i think that
just having the right mindset going
through those kind of things
can be the diff difference maker and i i
also think that especially today it's
like we tend to over pathologize
everything
right
well something bad happened so now it's
a medical condition of trauma or ptsd
we're going to slap a label on it right
when really it's like
part of it is just being a human right
like do people honestly expect that
they're going to go through life without
ever having problems like life is a
video like you know think of life as a
video game are there any levels that are
not hard like what if the level was just
like nothing right it's like
we're always going to have problems in
life so like
learning to live well
is accepting that we are going to have
problems and face challenges um but that
will often come out on the other side of
them better
if we accept that and act accordingly
dude i love that there's a sam harris
video floating around from one of his
new ones where he talks about exactly
that no interesting do you would you
imagine that one day you would wake up
and all of your problems would be gone
as if you'd got to a level in a computer
game and there was nothing there you'd
be bored you'd be bored out of your mind
problems are not going to go away the
problem that you have is the way that
you think about your problems and you
can drop your problems if only for a
moment if you can and then you need to
be enlightened and you need to identify
the difference between the self and
all that but the principle of
problems are there they're an inherent
part of life they're a feature not a bug
right and people treat them like bugs
not features it's like no this is this
is why you're here you're you're not
here to lie in a pool with a cocktail
for the rest of life
and you and part of what i talk about in
the book i talk about this um
concept called prevalence induced
concept change now that is uh a kind of
a dorky way of basically talking about
this concept called problem creep
and it was discovered by some scientists
at harvard maybe in 2018
basically found that as humans
experience fewer and fewer problems
we don't actually perceive ourselves as
having fewer problems because we just
find the next problem
but what i'm talking about in the book
is that as the world has gotten better
and better and better the problems that
we then find become progressively more
hollow so this explains why we have
first world problems right
so you think about it i think that we'll
probably all agree that compared to
let's say 300 years ago 3 000 years ago
the world is better right we're less
likely to go hungry
we're less likely to you know
toil in a field under a king who gives
us like these meager rations uh our kids
are less likely to die at any given
moment
but when you poll people only six
percent of americans at least now were
pessimistic bastards um only six percent
of people say that the world is
improving
and it's because we're always moving the
goal post we're always just searching
for the next problem and so
i think
when you apply that to daily life it
just totally messes with your
perspective on things because you can
either like kind of have these moments
where you're just pissed off because
like oh i was late for my yoga class
right or you can be like man this is
ridiculous that i'm living in
temperature control and have access to
food like this is amazing and i'm not
saying the world doesn't have problems
that we should solve but like
in the grand scheme of time and space
our problems now are
you know not that bad some of the bigger
ones like global warming withstanding i
guess
are you familiar with parkinson's law do
you know what that is
i don't okay so it's a law around
productivity and it says work expands to
fill the time given for it so if you
have three months to complete an
assignment the likelihood is that you
are going to do the assignment
10 minutes before it's due to being
right that's why you hand stuff in work
expands to fill the time given free it's
one of the reasons that time blocking is
a productivity strategy is useful
because you create time-bounded
constraints around different bits of
work that you need to do i was talking
to a philosopher friend last night on
the phone who is
uh and i quote trying nihilism uh as a
li as a life philosophy
[ __ ] hell and he was saying basically
the same thing that ostensibly he has
absolutely nothing wrong
um
but
he believes that there is a
parkinson's law equivalent of suffering
so suffering expands to fill the room
given for it in life if you don't have
that many things going wrong you just
magnify in on things that are ever so
slightly sub-optimal until they become
this huge big problem yeah
yeah that's that's basically this idea
that these harvard researchers are
talking about and it's funny because the
way that they
went about studying this is they're um
there's two of them uh one of them's
name is david lavari he was the main guy
in the study and the other was daniel
gilbert who's kind of a famous name in
psychology
they're in an airport because they're
traveling to a conference right and
they're in the line for tsa and they
make this observation about tsa uh and
that is that they are really good at
finding problems right and we've we've
obviously experienced this in our life
that you know when we go through
security it's like our bag gets ripped
apart because the agent thought that
this banana we had was like a nine
millimeter beretta right
uh or there's like some old woman in
front of us who's like 90. can't see
can't hear
can't walk she's in a wheelchair
and they give her like the full body
scan down because she's got like a half
filled you know bottle of hairspray or
whatever
so these guys wonder it's like okay
obviously better safe than atari but if
all of a sudden everyone started abiding
by the rules and like the scanners never
picked anything up uh no buzzer the
buzzers never went off when you had to
stand on that weird thing they never
caught anything
would tsa just let everyone fly through
like oh yeah have a good flight guys
have a good flight
and they didn't think so because the
tsa's job is to search for problems
right so they thought they'd probably
just keep finding more um flipping
problems over time
so to study this they get these groups
of people and they have the first group
they look have them look at 800
different faces so the job of the
participants is to look at face after
face and basically deem whether they
find this face threatening or
non-threatening okay so they're going
like threatening non-threatening
non-threatening non-threatening ooh
threatening
unbeknownst to the participants after
about the 200th face they start showing
them fewer and fewer and fewer
threatening faces
now the second study
same setup except it was with research
proposals and they had to deem whether
these research proposals were ethical or
unethical
same deal after midway through they
start giving them fewer and fewer
unethical research proposals so these
things should they should be black or
white right because like a face i either
find a person threatening or i don't
some proposal either crosses this moral
line i have in the sand or it doesn't
right
but what they found is that people
actually see gray so as people started
to see fewer and fewer threatening faces
they started to deem ambiguous spaces as
threatening they said the same they said
threatening the same number of times
right same with the research proposals
they started looking at these research
proposals that were kind of like pretty
ambiguous
as being unethical
so that's basically how they found that
as people experience fewer problems in
our lives we don't
actually experience fewer problems we
just look for more problems and deem
things that are probably not problematic
as problems
i notice this when i'm at work so i run
nightlife events and a lot of the time
the door staff will be just checking ids
very very similar to the tsa thing and
there'll be someone that will come up
who is exactly the same as the last 10
people they say their date of birth it
looks like them but then they'll they'll
feel like there's an obligation for
scrutiny because whatever the scrutiny
alarm hasn't gone off sufficiently for
the last 10 people uh can you give me
your address and your postcode okay
what's your postcode backwards okay can
you what's your uh
[ __ ] star sign they love that one
like once you start oh yeah because
that's going to rumble this 17 year old
that's using an 18 year old's id to try
and get in but another thing that i find
that i think this shows up in is when
you have let's say the people are at
work um and
there is a team of people that are
working a lot of the time if you're in a
meeting
people will feel the need to contribute
things that don't actually have to be
said so let's say that the design a
design that gets put forward for a piece
of artwork and everybody's happy with it
but there is a sense
that well i'm here to make some sort of
a contribution you know what what what
about what about if we what about if we
move the image not much but you know
just a little bit and it's this
compulsion to
to try and find a way to contribute as
well
and i think that you see that in in work
settings i know that i do it so again if
i'm stood outside of a nightclub and the
queue is absolutely fine
nothing wrong at all but i'll walk down
and i'll just move the barriers in
barriers creep out in nightlife a lot
and the goal is to keep them as tight to
the wall as possible and i'll just move
them
a foot half a foot like six inches these
barriers they're several yards wide and
i'll just go and give them a little
nudge because i'm like oh yeah that's
[ __ ] helped that's made a really big
difference to this queue of 418 year
olds who are all drunk that half foot
that i've just moved the barriers in but
you do it because you you try and
i think it
it comes from a
most of the time or a lot of the time it
comes from a virtuous place the tsa
agents are doing it because they want to
try and catch the crims right they want
to make sure that people are safe on the
but
yeah there's definitely a sense that
people just do [ __ ] because they feel
like they should be doing [ __ ]
yeah um
yeah there's actually some research
around this and the reason for this is
that um humans evolve to basically
want to feel like they're being useful
contributors to their environment and
this is not only internally but also
more importantly
um so we can show socially that we're
doing something and contributing to the
tribe because if we're standing there
and like just not doing anything because
we're consciously going like yeah i
think things are pretty good you know
but everyone else is working well if we
don't work it's like we'll get the hell
out of the tribe dude right and then
you're on your own you're going to get
thrashed by wolves or whatever and i
love that story you told about nightlife
and i would i would see it in my own
work like when i was uh
working at men's health magazine we
would do these things called wall walks
and we would get
every single article that was going to
be in the magazine including the cover
and we would go
we would go over what the headline was
going to be and it was literally like
you know someone would throw out a
really good idea but one person would be
like i don't know that i don't know and
then we'd have to like go on to another
one and this would take hours and hours
and hours right
now
before these started happening which is
hilarious is that there was this uh
there was this guy who ran the magazine
and he and the number two with the
magazine
would just go to a bar and they would
sit down with the entire magazine and
they would do this themselves and at
that point the magazine was selling way
more right so it's like here we have
this massive group of people all
spending time on this little thing just
being like yeah i don't know i don't
know
and then these two guys would just do
the same damn thing but arguably a lot
more efficiently and i think that that's
sort of a good lesson too for creative
work it's like we know feedback is
really important
but do we need feedback from 10 people
because it's like just so much noise
right where it's like if you just can
find one person that you really trust
and you're like this is my dude
or my girl whatever
i think that can arguably be a lot more
efficient there is a non-zero chance
that somebody is going to feel a
compulsion to contribute because of this
whatever contribution compulsion that's
what we'll call it i like it um there is
a nonzero chance that that's going to do
and for every person that you add into
the group
that increases yes the chance that
that's going to happen increases whereas
if it's two people you know you can just
is it fine yet it's fine fine fine fine
all right have a chat between two people
fine fine fine yeah absolutely man when
we're doing artwork amends one of the
worst things that we can do so we uh we
have a new dj that's coming to play or
someone's featuring or it's a
valentine's
traffic light party or whatever
and we put or a video this is the worst
one [ __ ] we put a video into the group
right with the boys and and the managers
throw it in guys what do you think about
this and it's just
a
litany of problems they've got that that
song's not cool anymore no one listens
to that that was big on tick tock four
months ago
the i don't like the color of the font i
don't like to diss that in the other but
if you sat down with each of the boys
individually and showed them it they'd
probably say that it was fine so another
part of it is the signaling as well it's
the signaling to the rest of the group
i am
somebody that looks at the work with
such a high level of resolution that i'm
picking up the things that you're not
and that's such a i i see it myself i do
it as well i want to show off that oh
actually maybe
maybe the alignment could be a bit
better on this should it's fine it's
[ __ ] fun people are going to be
looking at it half cut at pre-drinks
when they're deciding where they're
going to go out in a small window on the
bottom corner of something like it's
it's going on instagram this isn't it's
not the ending of a christopher nolan
movie
yeah totally and i think it's like it's
a balance right it's like you want a
certain quality but at the same time i
think we need to realize that
and i have the same problem dude like as
a writer
i'll spend like two days on two
paragraphs and i've got 85 000 words to
write like that is not efficient at all
and i've had to stop myself from doing
that like i'll have a i'll just i can
recognize when i'm slipping into it and
it's just like dude
let it go the average person is not
gonna know is not gonna notice anything
right and it's yeah i think it's a
definitely a tendency there's a quote
from thiago forte that he tweeted a
couple of years ago and it [ __ ] so
mad people put stuff out on twitter that
you keep with you
most of twitter is absolutely horseshit
but every so often you find something
like this and he said um one of the
interesting things about people who
produce um high leverage work
is that their content has a rough edged
half-assed quality to it because
polishing things to perfection is a low
leverage activity getting something to
93 95
and just shipping it
that's where most of the gains are
recruit getting it from 95 to 100
in most areas of work makes no
difference but the time sink you're
talking about to get it from
naught to 95 is one unit of time to get
it from 95 to 100 is two units of time
yes okay you could have done 295's in
the time that it took you to do one 100.
yeah and especially when we're talking
about i mean i work in media so with
content it's like
people like to think they'll know what
is going to do really well
we have no freaking idea so is it better
to put out like
one 100 piece or 395 pieces and see what
happens because you i mean it's just
more at bats right if you're hitting
let's say you're hitting 300 well if you
go to bath three times you're probably
gonna end up on base instead of if you
just went to one i'm sorry i'm talking
about baseball you guys don't give a
[ __ ] about baseball but yeah there's
probably in the cricket analogy that's
all yeah there's probably some cricket
analogy out there that's correct you
looked at um rights of passage of one of
these symbolic landmark experiences that
some cultures put people through what do
you learn there
uh so i started thinking about this
because i met this guy whose name is
marcus elliott and there's uh two things
you need to know about this guy is that
one he's kind of a seeker
so he lived out of a
well i'll tell you he lived out of it
he's kind of like you know he's open to
experiences he's kind of out there so we
lived out of a vw van for a while
uh got through college by counting cards
at casinos he was going to burning man
like way back in the day
and the second thing you need to know
about this guy is that he's super
brilliant so he gets his md from harvard
medical school and he decides i don't
want to be a doctor
i want to revolutionize sports science
which is a declaration that is like so
grand that it's almost bordering on
arrogance right but he actually ends up
doing it so he's the first guy who
really brought in like quantification of
um human movement and performance so he
can help uh he analyzes uh athlete
movement using all this high-tech stuff
and then he can sort of say hey here's
what you're really good at we need to
develop that and also like here's where
you have this injury risk and when we
see people move like that they have a
let's say 60 chance of tearing their acl
or something in a season
so i told you that to basically tell you
that
he's all into numbers and data and
figures right but he also realizes that
what improves human performance not just
of athletes of also of the average
person it can always be measured right
there are certain qualities that people
have that you just can't measure
that makes them able to do more than
other people right so to get to that he
does this thing that he calls uh masogi
and masogi is essentially a recreation
of these rites of passage that we used
to have in in the past that all cultures
would send people out on
so the idea is that you're going to go
out into nature and you're going to do
something really really freaking hard
and it's got to be hard enough that
you're going to face this moment where
you're like man i don't think i can
complete whatever this task i'm trying
to complete is
but by continuing on
you can reach this point where you
thought you reached your edge but you're
past it and you can kind of look back
and go well i thought i was past my edge
but here i am past it right so i've
clearly undersold myself in this area of
my life which raises this question of
like where else have i sold myself short
right so it kind of helps people expand
their potential and teaches people what
they're truly capable of and it's also
good at reframing fear because if you're
doing something really hard
and you're going to be afraid of failure
we're all wired to be afraid of failure
by sort of dancing on that edge you can
kind of see like man yeah failure's not
really that big of a deal and so yeah
again it's like this recreation of these
rites of passage that we used to face
all the time that all cultures had what
are some examples of the rites of
passage that his athletes have done
um so he's done one where they do one
every year
so one they got an 85 pound boulder and
they walked it i think five miles
underneath the santa barbara channel
which is like about 10 feet deep so one
person would dive down pick up the rock
walk this thing under water 10 yards
come back up the next guy would go down
on and on and on until this rock was at
point b right they've done ones that are
a lot simpler where it's like we can see
this mountain way off in the distance
let's see if we can get to the top of it
in 24 hours or whatever it might be
they stand up panel paddle boarded
across the channel once and they hadn't
really done much stand up paddle
boarding so the the point is that it
doesn't really matter how grand it is
for the average person there just has to
be a real 50 50 shot of you
accomplishing it so like my 50 is going
to be different than your 50 is going to
be different than your 50 you know it's
like
if you've only run say 10 miles in your
life
and you ask yourself could i run 15 and
you go i probably could like well could
you run 20 and you're like oh
i don't know if i could run 20.
go find out
right you're going to hit a moment where
you're like god i really want to quit
but by not quitting you're really going
to learn something about yourself and be
able to take those lessons back into
your normal life it sounds like your
spot science friend was doing that as
part of a group it seems like it was a
team bonding experience as well is that
something to learn from doing it on your
own versus doing it as part of a group
i think that if you do it as a group you
have to all be relatively equally
skilled because of that 50 thing like if
you've got someone who's just a stud and
then someone who like hasn't you know
has been on the couch for the last five
years it's gonna be a sort of someone's
either gonna make it really easy or it's
gonna be really hard for that other
person
um
marcus has done them both alone and with
people so i think you know if you have a
good group totally try it i have a
friend who uh box jumped mount everest
so he did
in i think it took
about it took less than a day to do
so it's uh jay alderton who has done a
bunch of other [ __ ] what the [ __ ] else
did he do
he did something else mental the box
jump was the most recent one but he
holds a couple of guinness world records
uh used to be in
some sort of armed forces
okay then became a
champion
like bodybuilding type dude like fitness
model type guy
and then decided to do these ridiculous
but yeah box jumped mount everest wow
well cameron
did they explode at the end he was good
so i think he um
the form his form was pretty good but he
was permitted to do is a 24-inch box i
want to say so as standard standard box
jump height but he was doing some smart
things he had knee wraps on um he was
stepping down from the box so there was
no fear about reba rebounding um i think
he was landing landing fairly soft and
he was allowed to put his hands on his
knees if he wanted to i don't know
whether he had to reach like triple
extension at the top either i think he
just had to get to the top of the box
which you know all of these things are
small but when you're doing it
20 000 times or whatever it was
throughout the day um yeah it would be
like 15 000 box jumps if you do the math
yeah it's something like 24 inches yeah
something like that i mean cameron
haynes's son
just beat david goggins
uh pull-up record in 24 hours didn't he
i think so um i saw him on a hunting
trip in september and he's it's very
impressive because he's he's a big dude
too like you know i would imagine
pull-up people being like pretty small
gymnast types but he's like he's a big
dude so it's pretty impressive yeah what
um
is there something
with this rite of passage
that people are supposed to do to add
some sense of sacredness to it either in
advance or afterward
um i think the sacredness happens
in those moments
yeah where you're like no i got i gotta
quit but then you don't quit i mean i've
done so i've started doing something
like this every year and um
it totally is where you're like nope
can't finish this but for whatever
reason you just kind of keep going and
it's like oh holy [ __ ] you know i think
that's when it really sets in what was
your one last year
um i've done some i did a running one
last year so i'd only run uh 16 miles
the farthest i'd run at one time was 16
miles and i did like 50.
yeah yeah i think it was a maybe mile
like
35 that i was just like yeah i got to
quit no way and then i just kind of kept
going and something kicks in at like
mile 40 where it's just like you know
you're in and one of the one of the
things too that um
i talk about in the book is i'm kind of
breaking this rule but in the interest
of getting it out to people is that
you're not supposed to advertise this a
ton right because a lot of what we do in
modern life now especially
physically is just so we can put it on
the gram for likes right we're not doing
it for ourselves and this really is
something that you are supposed to do
for yourself so one of the guidelines is
like you know you can talk about it with
friends and stuff but it's this is not
like i did it for the grant it's not
social media flex yeah yeah exactly one
of the problems that you have that's
great and i really like that idea the
the that's sacredness as well right
doing it for its own sake um however
i don't know whether you've seen 75 hard
which is a challenge that a lot of
people are doing at the moment it's just
like
yeah a lot of people are doing that to
water
two 45-minute workouts read 10 pages of
a non-fiction book stick to a diet
something like that right it's just a
simple
here is the basics for
nutrition training
bit of mental health and you're sleeping
well something like that yeah
those sorts of movements i think you're
going to see those increasingly kind of
like social powered simple
stoic
esque
all-encompassing lifestyle changes
and something like this you know if you
were to do an equivalent of sober
october which was it was and still is
quite big or dry january if you were
able to do something like that um i
think that you would get a lot of people
bought into this idea
but
it's inherently self-defeating because
the advertisement of it i suppose there
would be a way to say look
um you can do this as a part of it and
almost have the fact that you're not
supposed to advertise it as one of the
elements that you know you do you do
this maybe you could follow the page or
you know be a part of the group or
whatever and you would maybe be able to
speak to the those people that were
within it but outside of that you don't
you don't talk about it yeah i think i
mean yeah i think you make a really
great point i think it could potentially
be a closed group or it's just like
hey i'm doing this here was my
experience um and maybe you just talk
about it more vague you know um
you know it's like the fight club rule
you don't talk about fight club
have you seen the liver king on
instagram
dude uh yeah
well he seems like a guy that depending
on how legit or not you think he is but
he seems like a guy that's trying to add
discomfort into his life as much as
possible yeah for sure for sure he's an
interesting cat someone uh i had never
heard of him and one of my friends
texted me about him was like dude you
gotta see this guy i think it was more
just based on the fact that he's eating
so much raw meat which i think
um
you know
yeah yeah so you don't know what to say
i think it would be cool i've
i'm in contact with his team about
podcasts and stuff but
yeah i haven't really heard anybody go
deep there's not been a you know men's
health article written on him yet or any
of that sort of stuff and um that yeah
that mystique kind of adds a little bit
i it wouldn't surprise me if you see him
on something like a rogan at some point
soon
um
just because he's so
he he's very intriguing you know say
what you want about him like he's an
intriguing guy
yeah that's totally how i feel i'm like
would i do a lot of the things that he
does no
hell no
um i think that there's always like
especially with people on the extremes i
think it's relatively fair to say that
he's at an extreme
i think there's a nugget of utility in
in what they're doing i mean i don't
think it's irrational to say that like
yeah like organ meats are good for
people right it's something we don't eat
anymore and we know that it has it's
more nutrient dense than a lot of the
cuts that we eat now
good advice
is eating it at the expense of
everything else good advice i i don't
know i'm not you know i'm not a phd
holding nutritionist but i talk to a lot
and i they might push back on that but
you know whatever
go on rogan brian that's what we want uh
about the guy that fixed the patriots
oh that was marcus oh that was the dude
that was your same guy so was that the
patriots that he's got doing these crazy
things
so he um
he worked with the patriots that was his
first job out of college uh out of
medical school so he worked for them i
can't remember how many years but he was
there when they were winning some super
bowls one of the main things he did is
that they had i think it was like 26
hamstring injuries in the season
and he was able to drop that number down
to three
right so that that really helped him so
now he's got contracts with the nba
he works with some nfl teams he works
with mlb people he works with some world
soccer nascar
and yeah what he does is he basically he
doesn't make anyone do him ahsoki
because it's totally an elected thing
right but he
tells all those athletes to come through
about it and some of them do it with him
and he does say too he says uh
there are people who hear about it
and they go
no i'm not doing that like hell no he's
like the people who were like
yeah i'll do that instead of doing it
he's like those are the dudes that like
have it have that extra element like at
the end of the game you give them the
ball type people there's just you know
something about them like if someone
says they'll do that with me i'm like
that person's gonna be fine in their
career so
what
what did he have anything to say if you
fail you're misogy because obviously you
know if there's a 50 chance of you
failing it then a good group of people
are not going to get this done
you know feelings of disappointment or
insufficiency might crop up if you do
that did you have any insight around
that
i think that there's still lessons there
though right so he talked he talked to
me about one where he was going to do a
rim to rim to rim of the grand canyon
and um so it's like
45 miles maybe but it really what kills
you is the elevation
change it's
it's a lot
all right because you start at like 8
000 feet and in just a handful of miles
you're down to
2000 or like 1000 feet or something i
mean it's more than 20 20 000 feet of
elevation change easy
well more like 40 actually if you do the
math because you're going down and then
you're going back up um
and his knees just blew up on the way
down and so he got to the top of the
north he started the south rim went down
went across the canyon bottom went up
started to go back down and it was just
like i'm gonna have to get helicoptered
out of here you know
but he talked about how like that it's
still an amazing lesson because there's
so much adventure in that and you know
he was like even though i had to stop i
was able to get farther than i
anticipated once things started going
south like it's still an amazing
experience that you're going to learn
from 50 50 you should like if you are
doing something like this every year and
you succeed
you're doing it wrong
because there's so much in life now that
we
choose to do but we know we're going to
succeed i mean think of how people
approach running a marathon
they don't go i don't know if i can run
a marathon they say i don't know if i
can run a marathon in four hours or
whatever some time goal is right we know
we're going to be able to accomplish the
things that we're going to try
but we just like set these kind of
artificial time goals too so one of the
ideas here is like i want a true 50 50
shot every other year i should be
failing more or less you say that humans
are wired to believe that we can
that we're far less capable than we
actually are as well i suppose
evolutionarily that makes sense if you
were this like hubris filled [ __ ]
you'd be dead within you know you
wouldn't make it out of you the single
digit years of your life you'd have
tried to i don't know
tightrope walk across a branch over a
lion's den i said oh yeah yeah i'll be
sweet and then
very dead oh yeah those jeans would have
died off right whereas on the other on
the other hand if you're a person who's
going no i'm not going to do that like
that's ridiculous but you get thrust
into that situation which used to happen
to us all the time
right but you're able to make it out
then that gives you a survival advantage
so we chronically undersell our
potential and there is a good reason for
that
how can people push themselves
emotionally or mentally
i think
pairing the emotion and
emotionally and physical stuff with what
we're talking about
uh right now is important right but in
terms of like relationships too i think
that dudes especially are just like
freaking terrible with like opening up
and honestly like having those
conversations with a loved one or
whatever you need to you know be open
with people is
just as tough sometimes
for people as like doing this kind of
physical stuff it's like
i don't know like i know plenty of
people who could probably run 100 miles
right now if you asked them you'd be
like yeah i got this right
but if you ask them to sit in silence
alone with their own thoughts for five
minutes they would go absolutely bonkers
so i do think it's important to think
like where what am i bad at right and
sort of dive into that so like for me
i've done these physical ones right
but
i haven't done like a real psychological
one so i'm thinking of doing some like
extended meditation retreat or something
just to see
what the hell is going on up here that
you know
meditation retreats an awesome idea for
a ritual you know a rite of passage um
yeah there's a concept i learned from
isaiah berlin called the inner citadel
have you heard of this
i haven't dope [ __ ]
dope insight so um
when the world around us doesn't give us
something that we want a lot of the time
we recede into ourselves into this sort
of walled off garden a retreat into an
existential inner citadel so one of the
examples would be
if you
were in a war and your leg got wounded
you might try and treat the leg and if
you couldn't you would chop the leg off
and announce that the desire for legs is
misguided and that nobody should have
legs at all and i never wanted legs in
the first place you see this it appears
in tons of different areas right so
in the diet industry you know you have
um fat acceptance and body positivity
which is i don't need to lose weight the
world needs to accept me at the weight
that i am your conception about what an
ideal body or your idea of fitness is is
inherently wrong i'm fine as i are or
another one that you see in
relationships a lot is polyamory you
know how many people
are desiring to be polyamorous because
that's their genuine compulsion and they
believe in it and how many of them just
struggle to hold down a successful
monogamous relationship so polyamory
becomes their inner citadel and they
retreat into this right they chop the
leg off announce that the desire for
being single and monogamous is is
misguided and this inner citadel thing
comes up with what you're talking about
that you have people whose capacities
may be totally extreme in one domain
just a freak
strength endurance some sort of physical
attribute but say hey man would you go
to
five sessions of counseling with your
wife and sit down and genuinely go
through
the way that you feel
that's that that's their citadel right
they they're gonna retreat into where
they find their comfort which is the
physical pursuit um
or for women you know the reverse might
be true or it might be something to do
with body image or it might be something
to do with being disagreeable or being
forthcoming you know um but yeah that
inner citadel thing appears [ __ ]
everywhere
no i think you're absolutely right and
it a lot of it too is i mean this is i
don't know if it's related but it just
made me think about it is
sort of like
a lot of people have unhealthy behaviors
but their unhealthy behaviors are things
that society celebrates so it's okay
right so if i if i inject heroin or
smoke weed every single day i'm an
addict
if i thrash myself in the gym
i'm a hero
right but at the same time it's like
people use those behaviors because they
don't want to deal it's covering up some
other thing that they don't want to deal
with so to your example about the person
who can do all this crazy stuff in the
gym but won't like have this
conversation it's like you're just
compensating for this like you're using
this as a tool to like deal with this
other thing that you're not addressing
right and it's just like
what are people using to
to sort of
deal with this larger problem
um
and there's a range of social
acceptability
on correct yeah a lot of it's to do with
the framing of how both you and other
people see what you're doing
you know
i think that objectively you could say
that the person who goes to the gym
every night
is uh that in a citadel is generally
more effective and beneficial for them
and society at large than the person who
decides to take heroin yes however
it doesn't stop the fact that the
fundamental
mechanism
which both people are following is one
of escape that person is escaping from
something and i think that this is why
you're seeing psychedelics amongst a
particular group of people have such a
a renaissance so much popularity at the
moment that it strips away
your ability to hide from the things
that you've been hiding from for a very
long time
totally yeah i think you nailed it
you take a big gulp of ayahuasca and you
hold it down for 30 minutes
you're you don't get to choose
what you hide from you don't have your
coping mechanism anymore you don't have
the escape of
crossfit or powerlifting or hill walking
or bow hunting or whatever it is that
you do drugs any of that you know
[ __ ] netflix and cuddles wherever it
is that you go whatever your citadel is
those walls are down and yeah ayahuasca
is coming in with a huge [ __ ]
catapult
it's going to annihilate it
what about boredom because this is
something that
i think
has been completely eroded obviously by
the invention of the smartphone but
that's a type of discomfort as well
yeah so
i started thinking about this because
when we're up in the arctic we're
hunting right i think a lot of people
think that hunting is like this
action-packed thing it's not it's a lot
of waiting it's like yeah it's wait it's
waiting that's a lot of waiting because
we're hunting caribou as they're
migrating right so we're sitting on
these hills
waiting for these animals to come
through and they're not coming through
we're like all day right so
i didn't bring my cell phone i didn't
bring a computer i didn't bring an ipad
i didn't bring a book i didn't bring a
magazine i didn't bring all this stuff
right so all of a sudden i find myself
bored again
right just this like oh
the hell's this
so we had to come up with creative ways
to deal with our boredom right so we
would read the labels on all the food we
brought up you know we would read the
label we would read the tags on our
jacket so it was like oh this is coated
in something called dermazaq wow
interesting sounds like an acne
medication right
we would i did more push-ups than i'd
ever done in my life because it's like i
guess i'll just do some push-ups what
the hell else am i going to do i came up
with a bunch of story ideas for the
magazines i wrote for wrote some of the
book did all this [ __ ] came up with the
christmas list for all the people i know
like for the next five years right
so i basically told you that to say that
like
if i were at home this is radically
different than how i would have dealt
with boredom because i would have just
dove into a screen whether that be my
cell phone whether that be netflix
whatever
but when you think about boredom from an
evolutionary context
it's essentially this evolutionary
discomfort that told us
whatever you are doing with your time
right now the return on your time
invested has worn thin and you need to
go do something else tells us to go do
something else so imagine that you and i
are hunting and we it's a million years
ago we actually need dinner right or
we're going to starve to death and die
well if the animal animals weren't
rolling through when we knew we weren't
going to get anything boredom would kick
on and be like yeah well
you want to go pick some potatoes or
something like that's a better use of
our time right
so it's this evolutionary discomfort
that tells us to do something
that something that we used to do in our
past was often productive and improved
our lives
nowadays when it kicks on we have easy
easy escapes from it so i talked to this
one neuroscientist that basically told
me the way that we deal with boredom now
is like junk foods for our mind right we
just pull out our phone anytime we feel
the lightest twinge of it we're not
forced to introspect and come up with
something else to do
and this definitely has uh consequences
so it's associated with all the the
rising rates of anxiety and burnout that
people face why is that uh
so when you're
when you're focusing on the outside
world
like on a screen okay and and one thing
that i'll add too is that the average
person now spends 12 hours a day
engaging with digital media
more than 12 hours a day i mean it's
crazy amount of media right and this is
all stuff that's
100 years at most 100 years old so
when you're focusing on the outward
world your brain is actually working
really hard it's a it's a work state
when you have these moments where you
have to go internally and you're sort of
mind wandering that's a rest state for
your brain so your brain sort of relaxes
and revives so nowadays we spend with
all this media we take in we spend so
much time in that work state and so few
times so little time in that sort of
rest state that our brain just becomes
overworked and it's just like way too
much outward stimulation and focusing so
it seems to be that that is sort of
what's driving a lot of like the burn
out and just feeling like oh god like
mentally fatigued right whereas if we
spend time bored we're going to have
this moment where we kind of go inward
we mind wander for a while and
eventually we spit out something to do
so it's kind of restorative in a way
restorative yes exactly
um it also increases creativity
so this is pretty interesting some of
these studies i love are that uh they
will take two groups of people
they will let one group do whatever the
hell they want they'll put them in a
room and usually people just pull out
their cell phone right and just start
scrolling do whatever then they'll take
another group and they will bore the
living hell out of these people
and then they'll give them a creativity
test and the board group always comes up
with more more creative answers than the
non-board group that's simply because
their minds have had time to go
internally to rest to sort of reset
and good ideas seem to come out of that
and then there's also the fact of like
you you think about that william james
quote that's basically like your life is
essentially a collection of that which
you were aware of
well we're now aware of 12 hours of
screen stuff every single day right so
our life has effectively become
instagram netflix whatever
um
so when i talk about this
you hear the message of like we need to
spend less time on our phones a lot and
i think that's obvious it's like spend
less time on your phone spend less time
on your phone yeah everybody wants to do
that
everyone gets it
uh but the problem is is that when
people take say an hour off their phone
screen time
they now go well what the hell do i do
now i'm bored and then they'll like go
watch netflix
right well your brain does not know the
difference between those two things
so i advocate for thinking more boredom
and the way that i work that into my
life is i just make sure i have
20 minutes every day maybe go outside
take a walk where i'm just completely
disconnected i just let my brain go
wherever the hell it needs to go
one of the things that i find man when i
go for a walk now i do daily when i wake
up and then usually
uh in an afternoon so probably
accumulate
45 minutes ish of walking per day
my brain especially if it's
after a pretty intense period of either
learning or researching or working or
whatever i have more than enough stuff
going on in my brain to keep me
entertained for 45 minutes of walking
like there is boredom there but there's
so much bouncing around
that i don't really get to the stage
where i think [ __ ] you've got nothing
to think about it's like whoa whoa no no
no the volume was really really high and
now it's just a little bit lower um
and you probably figure some things out
so you think about like people always
talk about where do you have your best
ideas you have them in the shower
right let me tell let me give you the
[ __ ] life hack of the century for
this
so there is a thing called a shower note
pad so it's waterproof paper with
waterproof pencils and we've got one of
them in the shower upstairs and it's a
two different colored pencils now the
problem is that i live with two of the
lads so we just write abuse to each
other
in different types of pencils so it's
just like
comments and comments on the fact that
one of us has gained weight or comments
on the fact that somebody left some
[ __ ] dishes out last night or
whatever however the the purpose of it
is that if you have an idea in the
shower that you're supposed to right
that's awesome on amazon
i like it yeah well the reason that we
do have ideas in the shower is because
it's this time that we're like totally
unstimulated and we're just like our
minds kind of go in weird places and you
tend to find that people
you know they they think on an idea for
a while they'll be working on a project
and
the idea will spontaneously kind of
arrive like the solution will
spontaneously arrive at some later point
when your brain just has a while to sort
of process things in the background
have you ever been meditating and come
out of a meditation session with a to-do
list of things that you've thought of
during the
meditation session you're like right so
so i need to ring mum because i need to
let her know about this and i need to
tell my assistant about that thing and
i've got that that i got to buy the
insurance for the car the car get again
you're like [ __ ] hell like that
wasn't the purpose of this meditation
session but alas look at me with this
[ __ ] to-do here we are
is that related is the
boredom thing related to how quickly we
perceive time and our lives going past
do you think
yeah for sure well this is really
related to um new experiences
so
we also evolved to slip into predictable
routines
right just kind of do the same thing
over and over and the reason for this is
that gave us again gave us a survival
advantage if we could predict where we
would find food if we could predict you
know where our shelter would be on and
on and on if we had this sort of
habitual routine every day
we'd be more likely to survive
now we still have that quirk
in our modern life but in modern life
we're not really worried about survival
right
and what happens when you've done the
same thing over and over and over
uh your brain sort of goes into this
autopilot mode you don't really have to
be present and aware you're sort of just
going through the motions and that seems
to be associated with time
going by faster
so you think about when you were a kid
right
everything seemed to take so much longer
that's because everything was new and
you were constantly learning so sort of
the takeaway there is that
learning and doing new things
is kind of like a wake up almost right
it's like you're forced into presence
and awareness because you don't know how
to do the thing and it can slow down
time your perception of time which is
pretty cool bro you [ __ ] nailed it
you absolutely nailed it i've been
thinking about this for so long i put a
tweet out the other day that said um
life doesn't go past any quicker as you
get older you're just paying less
attention
and i got a load of replies from people
that were adamant that no well it's
because one year when you're one year
old means that that's 100 of your life
and one year when you're 50 years old is
150th of your life
okay that's true but you're not
absorbing your entirety of existence all
at the same time that's not how life
works the reason that your life appears
to move quicker is that you no longer
have a learner's mind you are simply
paying less attention what people mean
when they say
life seems to be moving so fast where
did the days go is i don't remember
where the days went like people spend
[ __ ] months on end
doing nothing memorable with their time
and then complained that they can't
remember it it's like bro you're making
your days forgettable you're not doing
anything that is worthy of your mind
remembering it you drive the same route
to work to and from work that's a
thousand journeys maybe that you've made
over the last couple of years they've
all been condensed down into one memory
think about the last time that you went
away on holiday the two here's the two
things the two things i've learned on my
research that you want if you want to
slow your life down and novelty and
intensity those are the two things that
you can manipulate most effectively
so think about the last time that you
went away on holiday and think about
not who you was sat next to on the plane
because you've done plane journeys
before but if it was a new airport where
you arrived and the person that greeted
you with immigration and the taxi driver
that picked you up outside and dude i
went to africa
five in a bit years ago and i remember
the book that the guy who met us at
reception
carried under his arm as we walked down
i remember the way that his shoes look i
remember the
the favorite bird that he had from the
local environment i remember his name
dennis it was like a given name he was
he was like rwanda and he definitely
wasn't called dennis um
i remember all of that
why what i can't remember the 16 digit
number off the front of my [ __ ]
credit card that i've had for four years
why is it that i can remember dennis and
his shoes and his book and his favorite
bird novelty and intensity yeah that is
the way to slow down life so for the
people and this is you know it's a mem
reminder for me as well i i get pissed
that it's the same it's your routine
that's causing that to happen
vary the things that you do and
vary the route that you drive to work it
sounds so dumb but like vary the route
that you drive to work very way you sit
in the coffee shop that you go to every
day you know say something different to
someone go up and speak to somebody the
more that you do that the slower that
life is going to exist and really the
goal of life as far as i can see it
is to live a life that in retrospect
you're glad you lived
very much of our existence is actually
lived looking backward at the days that
we've had because the present moment is
fleeting the present moment exists now
and now and now and now and now it never
exists for a prolonged period of time
but memories last forever
so the way that you can see your
existence is basically that every single
moment that you live can be a gift to
the future version of you to look back
on with pleasure
yeah exactly and i think this phenomenon
also explains why you have people report
that time has seemed to go by super fast
during covid people are like oh god that
like we're in 2022 how did that happen
it feels like it's been a month well
it's because we've all been sitting in
our houses the last two years and like
haven't gone out as much haven't you
know gone to concerts haven't gone to a
restaurant like just haven't done any
new stuff i've been traveling haven't
done a lot of stuff
where should people start with this
discomfort stuff what what habits have
you used in your life that are useful
for
creating a routine out of this
yeah so i kind of like lay out a whole
sort of action plan in the book
inherently and it's um
but i think that doing one really hard
thing a year like i talked about
more time outside i talk about really
the benefits of that and there's these
different like
doses and kinds of nature that we need
to add back into our life i think the
boredom thing is huge
in the book i talk about
i get a lot into uh nutrition and talk
about how hunger is like so important
it's this like discomfort you're gonna
have to go through right um i also talk
about the benefits of carrying heavy
things as a form of exercise that we've
essentially energy
[ __ ] speak to him about it speak to
brian johnson about it there we go liver
kings carrying all sorts of [ __ ]
yeah and uh and on and on i mean there's
a bunch i i mentioned in the book for
sure
yeah one of the things that he does
[ __ ] deliver king podcast here one of
the things that he does is he
purposefully
creates a uh physiological hunt
before he breaks a fast have you seen
this that he does i haven't no so he'll
do a workout uh that finishes with a
carry
prior to breaking a fast and
say what you want about him but that is
a really smart way to replicate
evolutionarily what we would have
done a little bit of a workout some
monostructural stuff maybe he's on a
assault bike or aurora or something like
that and then he'll do a heavy carry at
the end of his workout and you think
i don't know
if you can physiologically replicate
that in a more convenient way or if it
really really matters too much but if
you want to get close to what you were
doing
doing some monostructural cardio for
maybe you know an hour and then carrying
a heavy thing for
half a mile or a mile is probably a
pretty [ __ ] good way to replicate it
yeah for sure
for sure i will say that he's probably a
hundred pounds more than humans would
have been in the past but
imagine if people will look look it's
funny because like the paleo community
pictures hunter gathers as like these
jacked people it's like dude they weigh
like a hundred pounds yeah yeah they
were distance runners they were
endurance athletes yeah yeah yeah no but
that's cool though i love i love um the
creativity and thinking about like
i mean it's all it's all interesting and
like it's ultimately going to benefit
your life so super cool michael easter
ladies and gentlemen the comfort crisis
embrace discomfort to reclaim your wild
happy healthy self will be linked in the
show notes below what else should people
follow if they want to keep up to date
with the stuff you do
i'm on instagram at michael underscore
easter i got a website eastern michael
and there's a link there to a newsletter
if you want to keep up with that and
yeah i'm easy to find i mean google's a
thing you can find me there so thanks
mate hey thank you what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
you